[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 en donde analizamos la
actualidad de la eurocopa y la copa
américa a continuación los titulares
grupo cerrado pero un precio a colombia
en la tercera fecha del grupo p y entró
en carrera para pelear por un lugar en
los cuartos de final de la presente
edición de la copa américa en otro duelo
venezuela empató a dos goles frente a
ecuador con un tanto en el agregado de
ronald hernández tenemos análisis y
reacciones
albiceleste a la carga tras vencer a
uruguay en la pasada fecha de la
selección de argentina regresa a la
actividad para enfrentar a paraguay con
la mente puesta en asegurar un cupo en
la siguiente fase del torneo
escucharemos a escalones
italia perfecta la selección de roberto
mancini superó por la mínima diferencia
a galés en el partido de cierre del
grupo a tela euro 2000 20 la azzurri
termina con récord perfecto y sigue
soñando con un nuevo título en un evento
continental
gracias por estar con nosotros hoy y al
igual que en todas las emisiones
anteriores tenemos el placer de contar
con la compañía de sara castro directora
del diario 'as' colombia bienvenidas
ahora hola luis un gusto ya tenemos los
primeros clasificados a estas octavos de
la euro por supuesto que sí ya vamos a
estar hablando de ello pero la copa
américa regresó a la acción en el día de
ayer con dos duelos por el grupo pe que
comanda brasil
a primera hora venezuela y ecuador
empataron a dos goles mientras que en el
partido de cierre
perú logró la victoria dos goles por uno
ante la selección de colombia con tantos
de sergio peña flores y un gol en contra
de que elimina el descuento para el
conjunto colombiano fue obra de miguel
ángel por sarah que está pasando con la
selección de colombia y por qué hay
tanta preocupación sobre todo en el
ataque de este conjunto a ver el equipo
de reinaldo rueda suele tener la
posesión de la pelota en los partidos
intenta dominar pero no ha logrado desde
el punto de vista táctico encontrar
soluciones cuando se acerca al área
rival y esto
tiene dos consecuencias uno que el
último pase no es efectivo y tampoco que
los delanteros tienen la tranquilidad
para convertir esas oportunidades de gol
que se generan ayer además le dimos un
par de desatenciones en el punto de
vista defensivo que le costaron los dos
goles de perú así que este equipo que
estamos hablando que está en
construcción ya se le está acabando el
tiempo un poco porque se juega la
clasificación ante brasil pero creo que
de lo que se trata es eso no de lograr
esas líneas tácticas que le permitan
desequilibrar mucho más ágilmente a los
equipos rivales
vamos a escuchar rápidamente a los
directores técnicos de estos conjuntos
hoy le ganamos como ustedes bien dice a
un equipo que nunca antes le habíamos
ganado siempre han sido partidos duros
parejos
pero bueno hoy tuvimos la posibilidad de
poder hacerlo
y bueno es de las mejores elecciones así
que eso bueno más todavía cuando uno
viene de una derrota que dolió
como la de que veníamos con brasil
entonces la recuperación quiero
felicitarlos a los muchachos porque
lograron un triunfo muy importante hacer
un juego
igual o sea mejor ordenado
y ante brasil
consciente de que queremos y necesitamos
seguir a la siguiente ronda quizás se
nos va la situación de lo que
aspirábamos con este resultado pero creo
que como usted lo dice ya está está
abierto y hay que seguir trabajando y
ser fuertes para recuperar desde sacar
lo mejor de esta derrota y encarar el
partido con ya limpio de este resultado
como ya lo habíamos adelantado en otro
duelo venezuela y ecuador empataron a
dos goles
sara que podemos hablar de esta
selección de venezuela ya pareciera que
peseiro no se está acostumbrando a ir al
ataque pero con una defensa muy sólida
muy consolidada claro pero tenía los
recursos que tenía y en los primeros dos
partidos hizo planteamientos muy
defensivos entendiendo que lo que quería
era mantener el cero en su arco ayer
vimos una venezuela más valiente más
ambiciosa y creo que es importante
incluso desde la postura de intentar
poner dos atacantes el ecuador dejó
claro que cuando se defiende comete
errores y lo supo aprovechar muy bien
venezuela creo que
dignidad de la que hemos hablado en
estos días también hay que sumarle a una
capacidad creo que técnica y sobre todo
una idea un poco más elaborada por parte
del equipo de pc y de la copa américa
continuará el día de hoy compartidos del
grupo a uruguay que no tiene puntos en
el presente torneo estará enfrentando a
chile al tiempo que argentina chocará
contra la representación de paraguay
sobre este partido hablo lionel scaloni
escuchemos lo que dijo es un rival
[Música]
muy incómodo muy difícil qué
que sabe a lo que juega que tiene un
gran entrenador
y una generación de buenos futbolistas
así que
es un rival
es difícil para nosotros en el cual ya
hemos jugado dos veces desde que soy
entrenador y siempre ha sido difícil y
así pasamos a notas de la eurocopa de
naciones 2020 hoy cerrarán los grupos b
y c a esta hora hay acción en el grupo c
donde se disputan los duelos de manera
simultánea entre macedonia del norte y
países bajos partido que está 2 goles
por 0 favorable a países bajos mientras
que ucrania está enfrentando a austria
en estos momentos gana la representación
de austria un gol por cero más adelante
estarán también los partidos entre rusia
y dinamarca y también finlandia
enfrentando a bélgica como parte del
grupo b
pero ayer culminó el accionar del grupo
a con una italia que cerró con tres
victorias todas jugando en casa los
azzurri culminaron primeros del grupo
con nueve unidades seguidos de cales y
suiza con cuatro puntos pero mejor
diferencia de gol para los para galés en
este caso dejando a suiza a la espera de
un lugar en la siguiente fase como mejor
tercero pero vamos a escuchar qué fue lo
que dijo el técnico italiano sobre la
nueva fase
verlo tornar a wembley para nosotros es
bueno volver a wembley porque eso
significa que jugaremos en un estadio
fantástico y ahora verá mente pero ese
es el comienzo de un nuevo torneo
tendremos que jugar muy muy bien para
llegar a la final y esperamos hacerlo
tío avanti sara hay mucha ilusión en
italia por estos resultados un récord
perfecto pero podrá roberto mancini
llevar a italia al título de un gran
evento que no lo hacen desde 2006 hasta
este momento ha sido muy interesante y
muy emocionante ver esta italia porque
habíamos dicho que es la mejor
de este torneo el mejor equipo ayer lo
comprobó porque solo dejó tres fichas de
la base titular con la que había jugado
y vimos la misma idea de juego es un
equipo que presiona alto es un equipo
que domina en el mediocampo y que
necesita pocos toques para llegar al
área rival creo que está italia
emocionadas de la mística es un juego
que evolucionó y creo que mancini
reinterpretó mucho un juego que estaba
vinculado el catenaccio y que le ha dado
muchas variantes adicionales y que
piensa mucho más en el ataque emocional
incluso desde el himno y creo que por
eso es un equipo con el que todo el
mundo se ha identificado en esta
eurocopa no obstante habrá que esperar
cómo va a ser la segunda fase fuera de
roma que ha sido prácticamente que su
bunker pero por otro lado tenemos que
hablar también de gales suiza y turquía
respecto a estos dos primeros equipos
que podemos hablar especialmente de
gales que se vio consolidado y bajo el
liderazgo de carril brain gareth bale es
de sus jugadores que demuestran que se
puede ser uno en los clubes y otro con
la selección del país creo que ha sido
importante tiene dos asistencias en el
torneo y es un jugador desequilibrante
en lo que tiene que ver
el funcionamiento de su equipo gales se
mete muy bien a la siguiente ronda del
torneo lo de suiza también está
interesante apenas diferencia de gol
creo que la gran decepción del torneo
fue turquía es un equipo que hasta este
momento competía de manera clara
contundente en este en este tipo de
torneos y le vimos muy poco incluso
tiene jugadores que fueron campeones en
el lille con france en el torneo francés
entonces no se le vio mucho no le puso
picante a este grupo creo que hasta
ahora los clasificados han hecho un
mérito propio y está muy bien lo que
vamos a ver en octavos sobre todo lo de
turquía hay que agregar también que
habían retomado la dirección técnica de
señol günes que habían sido un gran
técnico para ello sobre todo por lo
logrado en el mundial del 2012 pero
pareciera que no caló esa idea de juego
con esta generación que está tomando el
testigo venía sin una frase una fase
previa interesante por eso es muy
extraño lo que pasa en estos torneos y
retomó las palabras de mancini una cosa
es el torneo en la fase de grupos donde
hay una serie de imponderables de
presiones emocionales y demás y luego
cuando empieza la fase de eliminación
directa
es donde incluso los que no son tan
potentes o poderosos pueden dar la
sorpresa en este tipo de partidos a 90
minutos vamos a ver qué ocurre con todo
esto pero a continuación veremos una
selección de las principales noticias
que nos dejan ambos torneos
la selección francesa de fútbol pierde
por el resto de la eurocopa al jugador
espa dembélé por presentar una lesión en
el bíceps femoral derecho que de acuerdo
con medios como marca le llevarían a
pasar por el quirófano
claudio bravo arquero y capitán de la
selección chilena advirtió que algunos
jugadores de la escuadra violaron los
protocolos sanitarios al permitir el
ingreso de personas ajenas al combinado
dentro de la concentración del hotel el
caso según medios chilenos como el
mercurio fue sancionado por la conmebol
sin ofrecer mayores detalles
el jugador de la selección brasileña
neymar dirigió el homenaje que la
canarinha le hizo al actual director
técnico opte por cumplir cinco años al
frente del seleccionado en dicho periodo
y te ha ganado 42 partidos con 10
empates y 4 derrotas que además tiene el
haber ganado la copa américa del año
ahora estamos llegando ya al final del
programa pero interesante lo que
podríamos evaluar rápidamente de ese
partido argentina paraguay y chile
podría verse afectado por esta situación
extradeportiva en su partido frente a
uruguay
bueno chile ha tenido esas
características en los últimos años no
es un equipo que tiene una gran
generación de jugadores pero estas estos
temas extrafutbolísticos suelen colarse
en los torneos en los que participan
creo que los partidos de esta tarde van
a ser muy muy interesantes decisivos no
hemos visto en esta copa américa ningún
equipo que tenga digamos su juego en el
punto más alto es una constante
evolución es una constante adaptación
creo que lo que se viene es un buen
fútbol y por supuesto más euro y más
copa américa muchísimas gracias a todos
por su presencia hasta mañana